journée de manifestations contre le pass
annie terre dans toute la france les
autorités s'attendent à des
rassemblement massifs y compris dans la
capitale où trois manifestations sont en
cours manifestation suivie par nos
reporters nadège abderrazak et dans le
cortège sur appel du leader des
patriotes florian philippot games a rosi
suit lui celui organisé par des gilets
jaunes cortège qui prend la direction de
ps de clichy on rejoint a tout de suite
bonjour guillemin alors est ce qu'il y
ait du monde
[Applaudissements]
ah oui oui pour une du monde ça il y en
a puisque le cortège a même grossi au
fur et à mesure au fil des kilomètres en
passant par plastination place de la
république à partir d'un petit millier
voire de milliers de personnes on est
presque maintenant à dix mille personnes
en tout cas plusieurs plusieurs milliers
de personnes toujours dans une dans une
ambiance parfaitement parfaitement
normal parfaitement bonne ce groupe de
seconde le cortège de gilet jaune donc
anti passe sanitaire anti obligation
vaccinale et dans lequel on entend les
champs maintenant bien connue des gilet
jaune depuis le début du mouvement
depuis presque trois ans avec également
ce mot qui revient tout le temps qui est
qui est assénée depuis le départ de la
manifestation liberté liberté puisque
c'est bien une question de liberté pour
ces courses et gilet jaune et je suis
justement avec l'organisateur de la
manifestation jambes rodrigues une
figure bien connue justement chez celle
et gilet jaune à bonjour géant mandri
gas merci d'être avec nous alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez organisé cette
manifestation 7/5 du coup de
manifestations maintenant qu'on antipas
sanitaires la particularité de cette
manif à défaut d'être différente comme
on le plante en dalle est protéiforme et
aujourd'hui on a des nouveaux arrivants
sur le marché de la colère et comme nous
gilet jaune ça fait depuis deux ans et
demi qu'on organise des manifs et qu'on
a l'habitude du terrain depuis bas
depuis toutes ces années à nous de les
accueillir de faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent manifester dans de bonnes
conditions et de pour crier aussi leur
colère ont fait que rester dans notre
continuité du combat c'est pas la
première mesure liberticide contre
laquelle on se bat nous gilet jaune ce
n'est qu'une troisième de plus donc on
reste dans ce combat aujourd'hui et on
accueille les nouveaux arrivants pour
faire en sorte que la manifestation se
passe bien et qu'ils puissent se faire
entendre de la part du gouvernement et
des médias justement de ces nouveaux
arrivants il ya aussi la manifestation
chez florian philippot alors pourquoi
est-ce que ces manifestants qui on voit
qu'ils sont qui ont qui ont alimenté ce
cortège pourquoi est ce que votre avis
ils viennent ici plutôt que chez florian
philippot qui est aussi une figure que
les hommes politiques connus parce qu au
même titre que dès que les gilet jaune
aujourd'hui on se veut être un mouvement
apolitique citoyen et on n'a pas à
suivre un homme politique qui a des prix
cadets destinée présidentielle qui vient
simplement chercher des des votes on
appelle ça de la récupération ici rien
n'est récupérable rien et a récupéré
simplement la colère à être entendu de
la part des citoyens qui manifestent
pour pouvoir abroger cette loi est
retrouvée a in fine normal de citoyen
normal avoir du respect pour nos anciens
qui sont battus pour la liberté et
respecter nos enfants aussi qui eux ont
le droit aussi à une certaine liberté
justement c'est cette liberté se passe
sanitaire c'est une atteinte
supplémentaire c'est la teinte ultimo
pas aux libertés selon vous non c'est un
de ses seins début si tu veux c'est une
troisième mesure liberticide qu'a mis en
place macron on est dans cette
continuité
je veux dire à un moment donné il n'est
pas normal dans un pays comme la france
où je finance de par mes impôts
l'hôpital et que je ne puisse pas y
avoir accès il n'est pas normal que je
finance avec mes impôts les films
français que je puisse pas avoir accès à
une salle de cinéma parce qu'on me
demande mon curriculum santé enfin
qu'est ce que ça peut intéresser les
gens aujourd'hui de savoir si je suis
vacciné s'il est mort ou vif si j'ai un
cancer c'est quelque chose qui nous est
propre c'est quelque chose qui nous
appartient et c'est le secret médical et
on n'a pas à me demander aujourd'hui une
carte d'identité pour prendre un café je
suis désolé merci jean rodriguez d'avoir
répondu à mes questions vous l'avez
entendu un les manifestants
particulièrement remonté contre ce pas
sanitaires contre la politique
gouvernementale or si on s'en tient aux
prévisions des autorités des autorités
on en attendait environ 250 mille
manifestants dans toute la france 200
cortèges environ dont trois à paris vous
le vous l'avez dit à noter
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le premier samedi
depuis l'extension du passé ni terre au
bar et au restaurant et puis et bien il
ya sept dernières annonces du
gouvernement ces derniers jours de
l'extension également du pass sanitaire
de son application pour certains grands
centres commerciaux de plus de 20 mille
mètres carrés dans certains départements
ce qui risque bien de ne pas apaiser les
tensions des manifestants présents les
esprits pardon des manifestants présents
aujourd'hui
merci game 1 oui les grands magasins
parisiens ont exigé le pass annie terre
dès lundi nadège jeu